ya know and welcome to another I would
brief um P session let's see um what to
do maybe a bit bit of the slower blitz
and to mix it
five plus three
exactly something that they do play
right when they do those blitz playoffs
I think for the World Cup they use
something like that
five plus three I think this is actually
what they use
okay yeah let's play before
yes
you
yeah hmm Kings Indian W in Quito
black now has a choice young this is a
good move
of the cases we're playing with c-form
makes the most sense
gain some space
no egos - yeah that's possible
six most likely
this position type is very solid of
course for black as you can see it's
just solidifying the center and
basically claims that
this small difference of pawn on c4
against opponents e6 does not matter
much this is
um not really wrong it doesn't really
matter that much
okay night eform maybe he wants to go
nighty form
you
not in time
should continue with this this is kind
of normal
maybe Bishop a5 could be an idea
Oh
[Music]
maybe this is interesting see what this
does
maybe CT xd5 now is a threat not just
maybe it is a threat
as he has no convenient way to recapture
hmm interesting
yeah I can simply take and take d5 and I
win a pawn right
you
surprising
that have won upon that easily
you know probably it's good to take him
how do we
go for the conversion I think I
definitely want
to trade his bishop pair off the board
this should be a way to do that
[Music]
let me move I did not see and that is a
bit a bit of an annoyance really
I cannot take six pawn takes my queen is
detective cause but it's got the check
this is pretty awful
you
rook takes as queen takes
hmm
you
No offered me a draw
you
it might not be a wrong assessment
the position but
to
first
[Music]
yeah it's just equal
maybe taking the draw wouldn't have been
oh why why is he doing that
now I can take c5 right
don't understand this
you would just take
and deform
but it's a trick what am i overlooking
and don't see what Oh let's take it
let's
strange
now where to put the Queen
see Queen a7
like the most obvious
Square
[Music]
No
you
hmm down c67 that's pretty quick
you
No okay now where do we put here I put
the rook c4 I guess yeah
let's put it
on a on a light square that is protected
and the C point is very very fast
so yeah I see he wants to go rugby - I
did not really
spot dad
you
so we'll see six rupee two
that's
odd
yeah bad technical clever me
that with Roxy form
you
the thing is my Golia should not be an
endgame a pawn up but to promote the
pawn I think it should just
- just it should just promote but
this way I'm not sure that I'm managing
this
need to be a bit quick ahem
you
yeah he will put the Queen somewhere and
I don't know where no get the trade
okay so
you will probably approach with the King
e6 King to e7 something like that
you
where should I put the night those
squares are that are covered so I have
to use a different route Eve 1 D 3 B 4 D
5 something like that
you
[Music]
that is a very surprising decision
you
weakening the light squares like that
you
night on d5
very attractive
and that's where I'm getting
you
yeah now I could go for this conversion
transformation I mean 95 rook c5 this
night against Bishop
that is a fairly early close to win I
guess but I can I can just go to b5 I
think with the king
they don't see how is stopping this
you would have to move rook a6 at some
some point but
I'm still very quick there
now grew ks6 I go c6 that is that is
just promoting
okay okay okay it's not immediately
promoting but close
you
and it's not it's not a completely easy
win
King before a6 King b5
promoting
but it's it's actually very
well-coordinated now that I look at this
King bee five night before d5 and c6
that sets that is very quick
now now yes two more okay six everything
else is just over
I mean over easily without any kind of
hope
now it shouldn't be
difficult moments now because the
rookies staying passive
or is loopsy a droopy aid to the
nuisance
see six is now a bit too early I think
you
yeah
I need to Knight him
you
CCC six now is the threat
I'm under bishop as well so
you cannot move the king
you
96 next I think that should have been
over somewhere before I didn't mean
like the odd thing was that he as he
takes is just equal I mean
have taken with the Knights and I think
it's just equal after roopd age that's
what I thought
he played rugby aid and this is more or
less losing but I couldn't put him away
I probably I probably did not spoil it
at any any point but these dis Musa were
not how not helpful
but ultimately it's probably a win yeah
okay so let's go
go of one more one more of those aha
Rudy something I think I've played a
couple of bullet games against him
judging that so you don't see that I'm
six and a half were half up against him
you
No
of the main lines of the 95 system
you
how
play this one
[Music]
I just I just have forgotten how
you
yeah why does with the c4 line is aiming
for control mostly control the center um
one idea that white is following quite
frequently is to play with f4 g3 and F
for this however after h4 is less of a
thing what age Ford did however is it
prevented me from playing Bishop to g5
that is not a big deal but something and
took knowledge now we should be six
kind of normal
one problem is here that I cannot so
easily move the Queen as then it would
take my bishop and kill off my pawn
structure
okay now I would never want to take on
h3 in this despawned formation
how do we do this
you can often take on the five and play
the night to d4 which is kind of which
is equal but also not very very
attractive in some way
ah
you
I'm not worried about Bishop e6 that's
not a problem F takes a some nicely
nicely covering the d5 square so I'm
preparing Bishop g7 and disposition
you
Knight f6 Queen f6 Queen d6 is usually
failing due to Queen f3
I think it's this is also the KCM
h5 can be played after which
got more than one option
trip to five or it should be seven
okay I'm wondering what white is up to
here because if he goes kingi - I'm
ready for f5
and this I'm quite happy about
you
I don't really think that this whole
line is giving white much anyway but
mmm I'm a bit uncertain what his best
option is
maybe you can play King g2 f5 e f g FF
or something like that
I will still do this just looks far too
tempting
you
it does not need to maybe age five
actually
maybe h5 sometimes can be an idea
you
okay after age five I think I can take a
four and play Bishop f5
King h8 is generally useful him
he takes f5 he also has to reckon with a
form okay so
f.e queen takes
hmm
No
you
yeah maybe let's get this roof into the
game as well
rupee 7f 7 is often helpful idea
you
young native form I thought
but maybe
maybe I'm wrong
let's do this on you after two minutes
you
maybe some sequence with EFG f94 could
be better for Wyatt
it's possible
you
on ticks 94 point x t4 Knight takes f5
seven
evaluate I don't think this can ever be
bad for me but it's tough to evaluate
yeah I've got Brooke f7 or I can take
first and then we'll give seven
he will have to play g4 anyway as I'm on
f2
you
gee form I can take a five th form
tough call I don't think it can be bad
for me but yeah this I'm
I don't think that this should be
possible I didn't calculate it but
i I just doubt that white can survive
this position
I take age three
maybe can survive it
it looks pretty terrible but maybe it's
not
sorry not losing straightaway
came
okay let's take this
now there is no window I thought a move
like we have six or so but there is not
I'm not threatening all that much
it's the amazing thing Queen d7 this qh2
just about
you
hmm what a weird would have weird
situation
I really thought that this is just a
question how I'm winning but I'm just
too optimistic I guess sometimes
how can you take deform
I definitely
cannot take h3 then
and it's bad
and I have to play Queen g7 I guess
which is not what I wanted
I don't know if Rukh if Queen f2 is good
that debt could be wrong
yeah this is still interesting Queen
takes King takes he cannot take the six
because of checkmate and I'm attacking a
tool the activity is still very very
much effector
okay now
can definitely go for this
chick
kratae to
yeah draw is probably quite likely him
you know I don't think I can
do much here with us immediately
maybe hook a3 was more precise I don't
know
you
you know I can probably trade
trade this off and
and I have to draw with two on two
against one
you
so some trick that would see
No
you
I should be able to play h6
you
and just stay
you
some of the king of porn endings could
actually be a draw but
I don't really want to calculate this
you
can go to f6 and then what not much
right I can just
Stadium
I always have to check for little tricks
sometimes it's surprising that actually
something could work okay this is this
is a little something
King f6 and then rook check
you
you
yeah I don't know probably there were
some mistakes in the game but it looked
reasonably correct it didn't look like
some crapshoot in my mind I was maybe
too optimistic I think here I like this
position highlighted a lot but I
couldn't quite
he growled let's aim this this is a very
critical situation so 94 is not given by
the engine okay now it is given by the
engine
a slightly better
you
now this is interesting it's good now
would be f7 as cool and this doesn't
seem to be so good
according to the engineer with night c2
yes that's a good one
simply keeping everything under control
the eye that looks stronger I don't have
this as this is hanging and my structure
is a mess
yam 9f5 is much more tempting but it's
not good so I mean in comparison it's
not good
so here
akes takes Oh Queen aah that is a move
that I should have thought about
he only has luke age - and then this one
very cool variation it ends in a draw
but a comfortable draw it seems and
Queen d7 this is not so great
look h2 would have been better even and
this is this should be equal I think
so
yeah and now maybe the cleanest one is
indeed a form but it's not really a
problem I think at the end of the day we
will always trade this is that better
so route d7
King abrooke a seven
I'm still drawing this I guess
I'm thinking I could this
it's essentially the same thing as in
the game that sets a draw so here around
here this was interesting
okay this
you
you
maybe here I can improve 47
one thing that I never really saw is
that in this situation I have Queen to
f6 it's a bit of an odd idea but it
works right I mean he cannot take
because of checkmate and I'm able to
take this next this is an important
resource that I did not see during the
game I felt like 94 almost has to be
played and what I have what I missed was
simply and here who gave 7 now that was
the second thing that I didn't see what
I essentially missed is I saw this line
but I didn't see night c2 I just looked
at that capture and I'd see to was just
very cool headed and better for white
and after this I'm getting I'm getting
into some um yeah yeah I'm okay let's
say but the screen ahead after night c2
I would have been into some substantial
trouble don't even know how
I could continue here still a bit messy
but my structure is a complete wreck
okay guys that was already thirty-six
minutes of this video and this is one of
those pre-recorded ones we don't have
that much time thanks for watching
I'll be back shortly with another video
probably something that is not there is
not a blitz blitz content something with
analysis or look at my game of my games
thanks for watching bye bye